ground news is combating divisiveness in
media ground is a news comparison
platform that helps you see multiple
perspectives for any news story so you
can be more of a well-rounded news
reader download the free app at
ground.newslash Pacman welcome to the
show we're going to be doing a variety
of different vaccine related discussions
today some of them are very depressing
like this first one some of them have me
sort of cautiously optimistic even if
it's for sort of weird or cynical
reasons but we'll get to that in a
moment I want to start with a new poll
that can contextualizes the why of so
many uh people not getting the vaccine
the kobit 19 vaccine any of the covid-19
vaccines that are available and we've
been talking about these really pathetic
low numbers where we have endless
millions millions millions of vaccines
available and we're struggling to even
vaccinate 500 000 uh people per day in
terms of one dose remember it being
mostly two dose vaccines that's probably
only about 280 or 300 000 additional
fully vaccinated people per day we know
that it's Republicans who are
overwhelmingly the anti-vaccine
individuals and we've sort of seen some
polling generally talk about oh you know
if uh
the vaccine were to be fully approved by
the FDA one-third of the current
anti-vaxxers would go and get vaccines
and then we say well is that true or is
that just the excuse they're coming up
with now and when the vaccines are fully
approved rather than just for emergency
use they'll come up with some other
reason or they just won't come up with
any reason and they'll just never go we
have a disturbing new poll which finds
that 20 of Americans believe the
government is injecting microchips into
their bodies hit the body with a
microchip in the vaccines and this is
shocking half of Americans believe it is
possible believe it is possible okay
listen to this
um uh where is the start of this polling
information an economist you gov poll
released last week did not attempt to
link false beliefs to social media use
but it did find wide confidence in a
popular conspiracy theory among one in
five Americans The Economist sasukev
asked 1500 Americans to respond to a set
of statements including the U.S
government is using the vaccine to
microchip the population five percent of
all respondents one in 20 this is a
representative sample one in 20.
said it it is definitely true that the
U.S is microchipping people with a
covid-19 vaccine 15 said it's probably
true so you've got 20 percent of the
country who believes it is either
definitely or probably true that people
are getting microchipped by the
government for some kind of subsequent
tracking presumably by the covid vaccine
and then look at this fewer than half of
respondents just 46 percent said it was
definitely false so between the 20 who
think it's definitely or probably true
and those who think it's definitely
false uh you've got an additional uh
huge portion of the population that
thinks you know it's unlikely but
possible or plausible that people are
being microchipped by these vaccines as
the article points out the debunk theory
has circulated widely in the last year
proponents suggest implanted chips will
be used at some future date to subjugate
Humanity Reuters reported in 2020 one
video in support was viewed 27 000 times
well that's not that much but it's still
disturbing
um the belief in the microchip
conspiracy was the most commonly held
was most commonly held by lower income
voters white non-college educated
Americans that that white non-college
educated group continues to be a very
problematic group and Hispanic
respondents and I've spoken about that
before as well as an immigrant from
South America myself was very in touch
with a variety of these communities in
the U.S uh that is and and that when I
was doing the Spanish show in the
lead-up to the election on the Estrella
Network the amount of anti-vaccine
conspiracy type stuff I was getting in
Spanish was disturbing I told some
stories about interactions a couple
weeks ago in Miami with some Cuban
Americans who believed the vaccine
magnetized my mom I told that story on
the bonus show and others so nothing
there is particularly surprising now the
one thing I continue to bring up about
this this microchip uh conspiracy is
other than you know when the first
question that I don't know listen I
don't know what the first question is
one question we would ask would be does
the technology exist to inject such a
microchip into people through a vaccine
through a syringe that is the size of
the coveted vaccine syringe the the
medical research I've looked at says
it's not even possible we don't we're
not aware at least of that technology
now a cons a good conspiracy theorist
would say well David come on they're
keeping it secret that they have such
little microchips and that becomes
indefeasible and it's endless cynicism
but the bigger question for me is why
would you need to do this to track
people when almost everybody is carrying
something around that provides a wealth
of information about us including our
location meaning our mobile phones in
addition to that most people's credit
cards debit cards now also have chips on
them which if you wanted to have it do
dual uh do the Dual role of also
tracking people you could do it that way
why would the government need to
microchip people via an optional vaccine
when everybody's already carrying around
a phone and most people carry are
carrying around a debit or a credit card
so it doesn't even pass the sniff test
but
um the the this is really it it has
spread like a mind virus now just one
other thing
um two out of five oh a couple so so
just a few other notes from this poll 17
of respondents thought that it was
definitely or probably true that
vaccines have been shown to cause autism
17 of instead of 20 who believe the
microchip thing also completely debunked
and then lastly two out of five
Americans set the statement millions of
illegal votes were cast in the 2020
general election and the threat of the
virus was exaggerated for political
reasons were probably or definitely true
that's 40
more than half of respondents who
identified as trumpists believed that
there was truth to those statements so
this is really really bad it doesn't
seem to be getting dramatically better
but but but but
um there is one little bit of news about
which we can maybe be optimistic when it
comes to vaccines and I want to talk
about that next I don't yet know the
reasons why the this is happening but
yesterday morning Fox News daytime so
not like the Tucker Carlson Laura
Ingraham Sean Hannity stuff the daytime
stuff that they claim is news
um seems to have been noticeably more
pro-vaccine now we're ultimately going
to come back to the reality about Fox
coverage about vaccines for months now
which is much like with the election was
stolen conspiracy theories they while
maybe not outright promoting
anti-vaccine sentiment were causing
anti-vaccine sentiment under the guise
of talking about freedom and by hosting
all sorts of so-called vaccine Skeptics
and anti-vaxx people so they've sort of
made the bed that they are now sleeping
in but yesterday I started seeing a
number of more
less overtly hostile to the vaccine's
videos could the explanation be the
rubber is meeting the road and Fox News
is actually starting to worry about
litigation because the Delta variant is
spreading it's increasingly clear that
this is overwhelmingly hitting
unvaccinated people I don't know what
the explanation is but let's take a look
at a couple of Clips here is an exchange
on Fox and Friends Brian Kilmeade
continues to be a very strong vaccine
hesitant voice although he admits in
this clip that he is vaccinated that's a
good thing but here he and Steve Doocy
sort of start mixing it up about
vaccination and the possibility that Max
masks are coming back on but listen if
you didn't get a vaccination that's your
choice and if you did like I did and and
they did so that's good it's good that
he's saying he got it it's good that
he's saying he got it even if he has all
the ifs ands and buts and maybe you did
then you should not wear a mask and if
you didn't if you want to go cliff
diving this weekend you don't have to
check with me it seems a little
dangerous but I'm not going to judge you
you and if you go ahead and put yourself
in danger if you feel as though this is
not something for you don't do it but
don't affect my life 99 of the people
who are dying from covid are
unvaccinated that's a fantastic
statistic to be putting out to this
audience and uh I am glad listen when
Steve ducey's the voice of reason you
know that everybody around you is making
no sense that's their choice they don't
want to die uh so they are the
administration and the government is
saying we need the mass mandate to
protect the unvaccinated that that is
not that's not their job it's not their
job to protect anybody so that is
absolutely fascinating for a couple of
different reasons first of all uh Brian
kill media insists well Steve if it's
mostly the unvaccinated getting sick and
dying that's their choice and then Steve
Ducey says well they don't want to die
Steve Ducey has hit on something that's
really important to some degree and I
know some in the audience don't like
this perspective to some degree the
anti-vaxx people a lot of these
anti-vaxx Republicans are just victims
of disinformation and Steve Ducey is
right they don't want to die it's not
that they you know want to be martyred
making some kind of weird political
statement by not getting vaccinated and
then dying but the real Whopper here is
when kilmead says it's not the
government's job to protect anybody even
small government conservatives so-called
concede that they don't want the
government involved in almost anything
but where they do want the government
involved is to protect people now
stereotypically what they mean by that
is from foreign threats from foreign
militaries from bombs from terrorists
but a pandemic is a global and a
domestic threat it's not a foreign army
it's a virus apparently in Brian
kilmeade's mind that doesn't count or
that's a different story but they are by
encouraging vaccination the Biden
Administration is providing for the
common defense of the country of
Americans uh it would be you know is
kill meat okay with the FDA and food
inspection or is it listen it's People's
Choice to just hey you know that chicken
might be bad uh the the the Romaine or
the spinach it might have who knows what
we don't need FDA it's basically people
need to figure out their risk tolerance
no that's ridiculous and I've not heard
him come out against that although maybe
he would I don't know
um and lastly
although it's mostly the unvaccinated
it's not only the unvaccinated there are
people who are vaccinated and will still
get sick and there are people who can't
get vaccinated because of medical
conditions so the willingly unvaccinated
yes they mostly put themselves at risk
but they're also putting at risk other
people
immunocompromised and others also
complete blindness to their own
Network's role in fomenting this stuff I
mean have they seen Tucker's show have
they seen Laura Ingram show Etc that's
part of the reason that this is going on
but again here's another example here's
another daytime Fox clip from yesterday
where they seem to be very clearly
telling telling Their audience go and
get vaccinated I mean to them they're
going to feel like they're being
punished the unvaccinated should be
wearing masks in close quarters but that
could also be something that's
recommended rather than mandated this is
a propaganda Doctor Who who uh met with
Trump to go over Trump's cognition right
I mean this this is a full full-blown
Fox News propagandist but even he's
saying this stuff and I'm glad he is
quick question for you with this Delta
variant spreading across the country and
we see it's affecting the the stock
markets right now how important is it
for people to get vaccinated and where
can they get more information on where
to get a shot it's very important that
people get vaccinated because two shots
of Pfizer the modern vaccine is still
giving you almost 90 percent protection
against this and and 95 to 100
protection against hospitalization
hugely important you can get your
vaccine from a local pharmacy your
physician can tell you where to get it
they're they're really all over the
place very easy to get a vaccine right
now the public health centers all have
it there are vaccine centers still going
we're having a low compliance rate the
Delta variant needs to be a wake-up call
to get vaccinated so this is really
really good that they are doing that now
why are they doing it could be fear of a
lawsuit you heard him say oh the stock
market was down I'm Eva I don't know why
I have this vision of you know so some
uh I don't even want to stereotype
someone who doesn't own any stocks and
hasn't wanted the vaccine hearing whoa
whoa whoa wait a second the stock
market's declining because of
uncertainty now I'm gonna go and get
vaccinated as funny as that would be I
don't care what it takes to get these
people vaccinated and if it's the stock
market going down whether or not not it
affects them whether or not they own a
single fraction of a share or whether
it's a Fox News doctor that Trump likes
saying go and get whatever it takes it's
good that a little bit during the day
yesterday the tide seem to be turning a
little bit on Fox News so that's a good
thing we are very close to the 16th
anniversary of the David Pacman show I
know it's hard to believe how could I
have started a show when I was only five
years old it's shocking to you it's
shocking to my parents it's shocking to
everybody but alas we are almost at our
16th anniversary and in honor of that to
celebrate that we will be doing a one
day membership special at joinpakman.com
how can you not miss out just get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com and then
Monday morning August 16th you'll get a
beautiful perfect email telling you
exactly how to Avail yourself of this
membership discount
I've been on Fox News a couple of times
if I'm ever invited back ground news is
one of the first things I would use to
get my head in the game and prepare
myself for the interview because ground
news is a news source comparison
platform that lets you compare how
Outlets from the left right and Center
are reporting on a story it makes it
easy to see the nuances of how sources
with differing political biases are
covering a story and it also shows you
your news blind spot stories that your
side of the political Spectrum may not
have covered ground news can help you
build a well-crafted argument for
debating people you disagree with or
ground news can help you discover
something new about your own perspective
challenging your own strongly held views
on political issues be the most informed
person in the room download the free
ground news app today by going to
ground.news Pacman
all right let's continue today I'm not
even going to waste time telling you how
important it is to become a member at
joinpakman.com because we just have too
too much going on and it wouldn't be
respectful to people to derail the show
with such uh irrelevant innocuous
announcements so we won't do that a
little more vaccine discussion this is
also just a very interesting exchange
and I don't exactly know the full way I
would describe it but over the last 24
to 36 hours there's just been a little
bit of a different Dynamic about the
tone of how a lot of this vaccination
problem that the United States has is
being discussed I think most of it is
pretty productive here's an example that
is not very productive uh White House
Press Secretary Jen saki yesterday held
a press briefing and during this press
briefing she was initially asked by Fox
reporter Peter Ducey and then another
reporter sort of followed up about it
and the gist of the question was
shouldn't Joe Biden go and ask Donald
Trump for help so that Trump will come
out and tell his followers that they
should go and get vaccinated and of
course if you watched yesterday today's
program you might be thinking wait Trump
just basically put out an anti-vaccine
statement
now you want Trump to go and ask people
to get vaccinated and the truth is Trump
may actually do it because everything
Trump is doing is merely to hurt Joe
Biden and if the imagery
suited Trump of Biden going to him and
saying Mr former president I need your
help I need you to put out a statement
so that your followers will get
vaccinated Trump would probably do it he
would drop the anti-vac stuff right away
as long as he gets credit for it so
let's jump into this here's Peter Ducey
asking jensaki maybe Joe Biden should be
reaching out to Donald Trump let's take
a listen uh on vaccine hesitancy as
coven 19. by the way no one can silence
their phones in this room you you've got
to be kidding me this is Rise if this is
becoming a pandemic of the unvaccinated
and you guys are having a hard time
getting a certain part of the population
to go get the shot right now what he
doesn't say is part of the reason you're
having trouble is because of trump and
other Republicans telling people this
Administration is not trustworthy that's
part of why you're having trouble he
doesn't mention you're sort of having
trouble because of trump president if I
never called former president Trump and
say I need your help let's cut a PSA and
tell people to go Trump would love that
wouldn't it
well first I would say that what we've
seen in our data is that the most
trusted voices are local officials
Doctors Medical experts Civic leaders
clergy from time to time this is really
important because when you ask people
who do you trust the most on these types
of things people aren't saying any
elected official now there are some
hardcore trumpists who are just
listening to Trump so that that's
absolutely a fact uh and that is where
we've really invested our funding and
our resources we've seen
almost every former president play a
role in putting out a PSA making sure
people understood in the country that
the vaccine is safe and effective we
don't believe that requires an
embroidered invitation to be a part of
but certainly any role of anyone who has
a platform where they can provide
information to the public that the
vaccine is safe it is effective we don't
see this as a political issue we'd
certainly welcome that engagement right
now the thing is because of Trump's
narcissism he has to be invited that's
the thing Trump wants Biden to come
begging and of course Donald Trump is
the one reinforcing the talking point
that people aren't getting vaccinated
because they don't trust the Biden
Administration we looked at that
statement yesterday and I'll put part of
it up on the screen Trump said Joe Biden
kept talking about how good of a job
he's doing on the distribution of the
vaccine that was developed by operation
warp speed or quite simply the Trump
Administration he's not doing well at
all he's way behind schedule a far more
aggressive schedule than Trump ever put
together
and people are refusing to take the
vaccine because they don't trust his
administration so first of all Trump's
reinforcing the talking point
that is preventing some people from
going and getting vaccinated and saying
you really can't trust Biden it's
socialist it's communist and people
don't trust the administration second
again Biden doesn't have to ask Trump
Obama Bush and Clinton did it on their
own why does Donald Trump have to be
asked by Joe Biden to do this and the
answer is because he's a narcissist and
now he's holding this over Joe Biden's
head or attempting to and working
against Joe Biden up until such time
until Joe Biden comes and says pretty
please sir will you go and do a video
and the the most remarkable thing about
this is Trump doesn't care about his
followers understand that if it's useful
for Trump politically as he perceives it
to encourage people not to get the
vaccine
he'll do the sort of anti-vax you can't
really trust this Administration talking
points if it makes Trump look good to
have Biden come groveling to him please
do a video so your people will get
vaccinated then Trump will do it one
outcome leads to death one outcome leads
to vaccination and mostly not death
Trump doesn't care he's indifferent
between the two it's whatever makes him
look politically the strongest that's
all the guy cares about now here was
where it got a little weird the next
reporter also followed up why isn't the
Biden Administration doing enough here
when it comes to uh uh giving Trump
credit for the vaccines I have a
follow-up to uh Peter's question about
sure and I have my own vaccine okay
uh in my follow-up even if the
administration doesn't partner with the
former president would he consider
highlighting or acknowledging in a
greater way his role in creating the
vaccines to assure the rural voters who
still support president trumpet are
hesitant to get the vaccine well I think
you're do you have data to suggest that
that's the issue that's preventing
people from getting vaccinated so that's
a great question on the one hand I've
said before maybe you got to call this
thing Trump juice and Market it like a
popular soda to these people maybe
that'll make them get vaccinated on the
other hand do we have reason to believe
that they're waiting for Trump to say
something because increasingly it seems
they want to hear from local doctors and
their local clergy for those that are
religious but we're seeing that the
communities the communities that have
the lowest vaccination rates did seem to
vote for president Trump okay but what
I'm asking you is if information related
to whether or not the former president
got credit is leading people not to get
vaccinated right or is it information
like microchips in vaccines and it
causing fertility issues causing health
issues because you're drawing a few
conclusions there that I haven't seen in
data but maybe you have that information
to provide no but I think it just it's I
think it's an issue I mean I think it's
a common sense that these are people
who've supported him these are people
who are hesitant to get vaccinated I
don't think it takes a lot to draw the
conclusion well let me be very clear our
our objective is to ensure all Americans
will will get vaccinated that would be
of course we'd love that Democrats
Republicans Independents it's not a
political issue to us the virus does not
sorry the virus does not look at
people's party affiliation we recognize
that the president's going to govern for
all people what I'm conveying to you is
your jump to a few conclusions that I
don't think data backs up in terms of
what the impacts are I think that they
both are making good points here in the
sense that it's very clear that if
Donald Trump just focused on saying
people go and get vaccinated listen it's
my vaccine after all give me the Glory
by going and taking the Trump vaccine it
would have an impact at the same time
the data doesn't suggest that it's what
elected officials say that is having the
greatest impact on whether they are or
aren't going to get vaccinated they say
it's local doctors and clergy we know
unfortunately that while they may not be
admitting it disinformation that they're
seeing on social media seems to also be
playing a significant role so I can see
both sides of that but if the point is
Trump wants Biden to come begging him to
help uh that's just more about Trump's
narcissism than anything else I want to
just briefly play for you a clip of what
might be and then I think we're going to
be done with vaccine stuff for today
these may be one of one of the most
ignorant and dangerous anti-vaccine
comments that we've seen through this
entire cycle and it's the idea of a
vaccine simply being an unnatural thing
it's an a natural thing and by
definition maybe it would be bad this is
a guy named Rob Schmidt who's on Newsmax
Rob Schmidt made these comments not too
long ago about five days ago I just
missed it at the time listen to what he
says about vaccination in this clip you
know I I the one thing I've always
thought and maybe you can guide me on
this because obviously I'm not a doctor
but when I've always thought glad to
clarify that about vaccines and I always
think about just nature and the way
everything works and and I feel like a
vaccination in a weird way is just
generally kind of going against nature
like I mean if there is some disease out
there maybe there's just an ebb and flow
to life where something's supposed to
wipe out a certain amount of people and
that's just kind of the way Evolution
goes vaccines kind of stand in the way
of that this is so painfully stupid I
mean it's painfully stupid in a number
of different ways first of all
um what does it mean to be for or
against nature I mean that vaccines are
made in the natural world they don't
exist spontaneously and often when you
when people make arguments about nature
sometimes they're just wrong about what
exists spontaneously in the natural
world they sort of say well that's
created by Society a good example of
that is one of the big anti-gay
Arguments for a while was it's not
natural homosexuality is not natural
because it doesn't lead to reproduction
you can't you know a gay couple or a
lesbian couple can't only by virtue of
their uh genitalia and reproductive
systems create offspring but then you
look at the natural world and you see oh
there's hundreds or even thousands of
speech species in which homosexuality
has been identified so what does it
really mean to say it's unnatural and
and so we kind of realize that it's
they'll just use the word if they think
it favors their argument now here he
sort of means to say something else
which is vaccination doesn't exist in
nature spontaneously if you understand
about poison you would know that a
really long time ago I don't know if
it's 800 years ago a thousand or more
people started to figure out you could
start to get maybe not quite 800 I don't
want to misspeak maybe it was more like
500 years ago you could start ingesting
very small amounts of poison that would
be deadly in larger quantities to
develop an immunity
is that unnatural by the way Rob Schmidt
is is talking about it because you're
taking the poison which exists and just
using a little bit of it and a little
bit more to build up a tolerance so
anyway it's a meaningless Point Let's
listen to a little bit more of it
um do you follow what I'm saying does
that make sense to somebody in medicine
well there are some reports that support
what you're saying there's one by Nissan
and colleagues from Boston in the Mayo
Clinic that shows among vaccinated
populations the diversity of different
strains is narrowing so it's going to be
fewer numbers of strains right now in
the United States we're about 40 percent
uh UK variant or the alpha variant and
we're about 30 percent Now Delta which
is the Indian parent they give
progressively weaker but the diversity
is changing with vaccination and I think
probably the best way to think about it
is vaccines really ought to be targeted
to protect the highest risk individuals
okay anyway so this guy is sort of
playing a little bit Coy with some of
this stuff but the point here is when
you say it's not natural
is correction of uh myopia via contact
lenses or glasses natural in the sense
that do contact lenses exist in the real
world is surgery that extends life for
conditions that would have many many
previous times killed people is that
natural is uh the idea that because
something doesn't spontaneously exist
without human intervention it would
somehow be bad is a painfully dumb idea
and unfortunately the audience that's
watching this stuff is exactly the type
of audience that would be likely to fall
for it so just horrifying stuff on
Newsmax and an argument that's not
really an argument one way or the other
we're going to have more examples of
stuff like this on our Instagram which
you can find at davidpackman's show and
when you're there you can follow me on
Instagram as well at david.pakman or
both or neither whatever is your
pleasure we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Barry Meyer who is the former
Pulitzer prize-winning New York Times
Reporter and author of the book spooked
the secret rise of private spies uh
Barry it's so great to have you on today
thanks David thanks so much for inviting
me on so to start with when we talk
about private spies we're not talking
about a private investigator because you
suspect your spouse might be cheating on
you we're really talking here about
high-level uh intelligence work that
often relates to foreign policy domestic
policy Etc give us like an overview of
this industry and kind of how it
developed
sure uh it really got its start back in
the late 1970s with a gentleman by the
name of Jules Kroll who created a
company called curl Associates and at
that time the public image of the of you
know the private investigator was as you
mentioned you know the guy in a raincoat
who like hangs around motels trying to
catch uh cheating spouses uh Crow
realized that there was a huge
Marketplace for Investigative Services
uh particularly uh from corporations
because this was a period of time where
there were a lot of corporate takeovers
and shareholder battles so he formed
what was essentially the investigative
equivalent of a law firm you know these
guys dressed well they looked good he
hired not only ex-fbi agents and former
prosecutors but really smart college
graduates who were interested in
investigations
and uh thus began uh this industry that
describes itself as you know corporate
investigators or or corporate
intelligence but basically they are
skilled investigators who are hired by
law firms Hollywood Moguls uh political
parties you name it to go out and dig up
information and often dirt
on their clients adversaries
and this can include I mean uh I'm
reading Lawrence Wright's going clear
right now the Church of Scientology
employs individuals like this uh
regularly we could talk about the
so-called Trump dossier and whether that
would fit the bill is the type of
product that that would kind of be
produced by this what are some of the
maybe less obvious uh functions of such
private spies
yeah so it could be anything from you
know what we think of as legitimate uh
use of investigators uh you know Finding
missing people it could be uh digging up
material for a lawsuit you know locating
Witnesses for lawsuits but the range is
huge as you mentioned
groups like Scientology which are under
public scrutiny
will hire investigators to dig up
information or even try to intimidate
their adversaries uh or critics I mean
when I was first working for the time
back when I was working for the Times
investigating Purdue Pharma uh they
hired Crowell to investigate people who
were suing the company and also looked
at me not long ago when Patrick Reed and
Keith was writing his book about Sackler
the sacklers he found investigators
sitting outside his house
um then you had cases where uh Hollywood
has you know made use of private
investigators all the time to intimidate
people there was a famous case of
Anthony pelicano who uh broke into the
car of a Los Angeles Times Reporter who
was looking into him so I mean the gamut
is huge what kind of Unites uh this
industry
I would say is the willingness of these
individuals these investigators private
spies whatever you want to call them to
use any means necessary to gather
information about their targets so that
and that gets me to maybe you know we'll
talk about in a moment
maybe some ways in in which there's sort
of a upside here to private spies but it
seems one of the concerns would be there
might be things corporations want done
or governments want done or whoever that
they uh would be worried about being
caught doing and the private
investigator provides at least plausible
deniability is that in fact the case is
that what exactly you know it's you know
basically it's the private investigators
have been described as the gloves that
lawyers put on when they don't want to
get their hands dirty and so that's
that's the concept here I mean they will
undertake uh
things that you know lawyers will claim
they never ordered and are shocked to
learn when it comes out they they in
fact signed off on it perfect example
being David Boyce's firm as you know
David Boyce is probably one of the best
known lawyers yep in the United States
he's most famous for uh the gore Bush
recount working for the Democratic party
in that case also for bringing the
litigation and the Supreme Court that
led to the upholding of same-sex
marriage you know a good guy uh in the
view in the eyes of most people
in fact uh his law firm uh signed off on
a contract that called for this uh
you know law this is rarely private uh
spying firm Black Cube who uses kind of
very despicable types of tactics to one
uh spy on women who were
bringing claims of sexual assault
against Harvey Weinstein and also spy on
reporters for the New Yorker and the New
York Times who were investigating uh
Harvey Weinstein's uh sexual
assault allegations yeah if people are
interested in that Ronan farrow's uh
recent book the title of the book
escapes me but it's by Ronan Farrow and
it's about the Harvey Weinstein story
outlines outlines that that quite a bit
um
catch and kill yes exactly now to to
sort of I don't even know if this is
Playing devil's advocate but to sort of
see it from the other side there are
definitely circumstances we could
imagine where the power of a government
the American government for example
could be brought down against someone uh
for political reasons or for reasons
that you me or anybody might say are are
not on the up and up
um is there a case to be made that the
ability to hire so-called private spy to
try to uh match at least in some small
way the government's ability to bring
political charges and use their
investigative power against an
individual or a corporation could be be
a good thing I mean I'm thinking out
loud here
yes I mean you know let me give you a
perfect example because there's a
lawsuit
playing out right now uh and the parties
of the lawsuit neither of them are
particularly attractive they're not good
guys in in Carmen Carmen parlance
but through a uh
just a bizarre set of circumstances the
defendant in the case became aware that
his emails have been hacked
and that his emails have been hacked uh
and dumped on the internet on this sort
of obscure law uh website where lawyers
for his adversary suddenly discovered
them and then used them in litigation
against him right
well after this case was decided it was
so uh it was subsequently uncovered by a
group of Internet activists what the
likely source of the Hacked material was
who had done the hacking and this
individual then went out and retained
his own private investigator to dig into
this and is now constructing a case to
expose the hacking that went on against
him and so you know there are many
situations where the use of a private
investigator private spy to defend
yourself to go and uncover wrongdoing
that has been taken place against you be
by a government or by an individual
actor private actor is more than
Justified if you want to think about the
way that uh journalists as well as the
media and consumers of media should
think about in information that comes
from private spies I mean there's sort
of protocol for how do you handle a
politician when you're talking to them
for a story you might be writing how do
you deal with an anonymous source how do
you deal with a sort of Civilian
non-public person in order to provide
them certain Protections in terms of
both the individuals and the information
that comes from them how should
journalists reporters and interviewers
be thinking about it's what comes from
private spies
well I think this is you know this is a
real motivation for me when I wrote the
book
and it was a there was a certain
Epiphany for me when I wrote the book
because I deal a lot with the the steel
dossier you know the the opposition
research that was done against Donald
Steele by this private investigative
firm that hired an ex mi68 against
Donald Trump just to be clear just so
the audience you met you you've done it
you said Donald Steele you met Donald
Trump Donald Trump right and Christopher
Steele is the MI6 agent was hired to
basically gather dirt on Donald Trump in
Russia
now
when this was being shot to Media
organizations it was implicit uh when it
was being shown around by by
investigative firm in DC that was in
fact formed by two former
Wall Street Journal reporters that they
couldn't identify the involvement of
this firm Fusion GPS or Christopher
Steele in the Gathering of this
information had to come from you know
sort of you know appear out of the blue
it was like you know Immaculate
Conception and uh when BuzzFeed
published
this information on the web and it was
embraced by particularly uh you know
opponents of Donald Trump
um and sort of became the focus of
political and cultural and media
conversation
uh for three years
uh it didn't come out until late in the
game that in fact this was a product of
these private operatives right we put it
together and no one even knew what
sources they were drawing upon and so
you know the the lesson I try to draw in
the book and the sort of issue that
comes out in the book is that you know
we as journalists and I consider myself
one
um is that we really have to be more
transparent with our audience with our
readers our viewers our listeners about
where this information is coming from
why should we give people who are paid
to gather what's effectively dirt
and use our
stories our articles our broadcast as
the means to disseminate that
information to the public why should we
treat them like whistleblowers why
should we give them complete anonymity
because it's not fair to the public the
public is being misled and you know this
dance has gone on this symbiotic
relationship that has gone on between
journalists and private spies for
decades but if there is one lesson we
should take away from the whole you know
steel Trump dossier incident is that we
really do need to be more transparent
they need to be identified as sources
whereas the FBI might be a source for
something about an investigation we
would identify where these infants are
coming from a government Source or you
know you need to when people have a
vested interest in getting out
information you don't have to say it's
coming from Fusion GPS you don't have to
say per se it's coming from Christopher
Steele but you damn well sure say saying
that it was put together by individuals
who had an ax to grind or were being
paid to plant this information this was
a paid research project by opponents of
Donald Trump absolutely yes absolutely
by the Democratic National Committee and
the money was like laundered through
lawyers uh for the Democratic National
Committee and once journalists became
aware
that Fusion GPS
and Christopher Steele
were involved in it
then they had a duty to go a step
further and to scrutinize those people
right to scrutinize that firm to
scrutinize Christopher Steele
and say what do we know about these
people who have their clients been in
the past and how does that influence our
assessment or analysis of how accurate
the claims in the dossier are in the
very limited time we have left is your
sense that the the dossier is sort of a
mixed bag in the sense that uh oh I mean
I'll just leave it there like for
example I spoke to Michael Cohen last
week and he said the thing about him
going to Prague he's really never been
to Prague it wasn't like uh well he was
in the airport but he didn't clear
customs and so technically it was like
he just he doesn't know where that came
from but there were other things in
there that either by coincidence or or
because they were better researched were
true
yeah there's there's no doubt that the
Russian government uh tried to influence
the 2016 election there is no doubt that
Donald Trump and his allies his son
embraced uh efforts by Russia to
influence the election I mean Russia are
you listening right I mean wasn't that
his big uh campaign uh rap so yeah I
mean
there was that Russia was trying to
influence but that wasn't you that
binding or that that assertion was not
unique to the steel dossier you know it
wasn't he was not the only person that
became aware of that what is troubling
is that the specific allegations in the
steel dossier one that that Michael
Cohen went to Prague when in fact if
Michael Cohen had a lot Michael Cohen
lied about a lot of things and he got
rung up for lying yeah but if and he
would have gotten her up up rung up for
lying about that and he didn't so he
wasn't in Prague for that meeting uh
that that Carter page another Trump uh
Ally was offered like this huge stake in
a Russian um
uh Energy company no evidence that that
occurred and the most infamous of all
p-tape
which uh has yet to emerge so there is
there is a lot in there's a lot in the
dossier which either has
um
not proven to be true or been proven not
to be true
we've been speaking with Barry Meyer
author of the book spooked the secret
rise of private spies uh Barry such a
pleasure having you on I really
appreciate your time and thank you David
I really appreciate your having me on
today
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so we
continue to try to sort out what 2022
and 2024 are going to look like
politically what's the country going to
look like culturally what's going to be
the situation with the pandemic what
will be the situation with climate
change and one of the questions that
remains is is Donald Trump going to be a
candidate in 2024 because as of this
point in time the nomination seems his
for the taking he's got he owns the
Republican Party Lindsey Graham said it
and jenk euger said it I mean there's
really no the guy owns the Republican
party they can't the voters can't seem
to to get away from the guy during an
interview two weeks ago or one one and a
half or maybe it was at like three years
ago no it was in the last couple weeks
um Trump told Maria Bartiromo that he
for campaign Finance reasons can't make
any announcements right now but he's
decided and he thinks people will be
really happy and that he's going to do
very well the first signal that maybe he
would be running at the same time when I
was on Michael Cohen's program the other
day Michael Cohen said I don't think
Trump is going to run there is a new
report very interesting report from
Rolling Stone
which says Trump is telling his dinner
plans he's planning to run for president
it was originally reported as Trump is
telling his friends and then of course
it's like it's not really clear Donald
Trump has friends or normal
relationships anyway but the report from
Rolling Stones Andy Kroll is that in
conversations with at least three people
top top Republican Source says Trump has
said he wants another run at the White
House brace yourself Donald Trump plans
plans to run again
at least that's what the former
president is telling dinner buddies
Trump has told at least three people
he's dined with in recent months that he
plans to run in 24 a former senior
official at the RNC tells Rolling Stone
quote I have three friends who have had
dinner with him in the last couple of
months all three reported that his
current plans are to run for president
in 2024. the former RNC official says
um now whether he does or not is a
different issue we've still got three
years to go but he's telling people that
the xrnc official says the first two
dinners took place in late spring but
the third dinner happened in the last
two weeks the first two companions came
away from their conversation convinced
Trump was serious and running the third
said he left the dinner not 100 sure
Trump wants to run but he likes being in
the conversation he wants to freeze the
field and he wants his name out there
spokeswoman for Trump did not respond to
requests for comment about Trump's
recent dinner conversations and whether
he plans to run for president again I
think it's a completely legitimate thing
to mention that just because Trump says
he's going to run and just because Trump
might really intend to run he may not
run and I I continue to say it's his
health that may be a factor in that uh
there it could be of serious losses in
2022.
um it could be that he's talked out of
it in some way I could at the same time
believe that Trump believes he's running
and yet he won't run in the end a couple
more things from the article a former
Trump advisor who speaks with Trump
members of Trump's Inner Circle says
he's been briefed on similar
conversations that reflect the former
president's current thinking the
ex-advisor says Trump started to give
indications in private back in May
that he was leaning towards running
again and that the more recent signs
suggest he wants to run the ex-advisor
says all the people I talk to who deal
with him directly think as of now he is
running now what is why do we care about
this guys can't we move on the fact that
this guy number one is like a baby
dictator and his supporters are still
with him number two he lost everything
for Republicans he lost them uh the
house in 2018 he lost them the senate in
2020 he lost them the White House in
2020 he plays Coy with the vaccine but
gets it in secret but then tells him in
March and they don't get it and it's not
clear he's responsible for their deaths
and it's not clear they even know or
care and he still has the vast majority
of the Republican electorate behind him
and at least then from a public
standpoint the majority of the
Republican officials behind him not only
does it tell us how broken depraved and
disgusting this Republican party is and
this electorate is it tells us a lot
about the fact that this guy could still
be a major player if not the presumptive
nominee if he chooses to run and if he's
healthy enough to run in 2024 it's quite
stunning and uh you know what what was
the mistake many of us myself included
made in 20 in 2016.
I overestimated the intelligence of the
Republican primary electorate number one
and number two I overestimated the
degree to which the non-wacky right
Wingers would uniformly realize the
danger of trump because remember
overwhelmingly why when we say who's to
blame for Trump winning in 2016. well
yeah the guy chose to run sure but we've
got to blame the people who vote for who
voted for him primarily
but remember those people who say
they're on the left who in 2016 were
saying you know Hillary and Trump
they're two sides of the same coin
what that is also partially to blame so
the mistake I made in 2016 was I
overestimated the intelligence of the
Republican electorate never to make this
guy their nominee and I overestimated
the urgency of the entire electorate in
total so that we would have enough
Independence and left Wingers and
Democrats and progressives and whoever
else to say no no there's nothing
similar about these two other than
they're both members of homo sapiens
we've got to get out there and vote for
Hillary Clinton and that's why it's so
dangerous now and that's why the the
fact that he still owns this party is so
scary and why the fact that at least
based on these reports he plans to run
is something that should horrify us all
we're continuing to learn more from this
forthcoming book by Carol lenig and
Philip Rucker from The Washington Post
and it seems like it's almost every day
we get something new from this book but
the latest one is based on excerpts that
now point out that Donald Trump talked
to Carol lenigan Philip Rucker so this
is actually super super interesting
um Trump granted the authors of this new
book
an hours-long interview the book is
called I alone can fix it now you might
be wondering why exactly would he do
that
and
um they actually talk about this uh in
this Vanity Fair piece where they point
out Donald Trump previously turned down
speaking to them for a prior book this
time he wanted to talk to them and they
actually say Trump had invited us to
Mar-A-Lago let me make sure we have this
on screen trumpet invited us to
Mar-A-Lago to interview him for this
book he had declined an interview for
our first book about his presidency and
when a very stable genius was published
in January of 2020 attacked us
personally and branded our reporting a
work of fiction but Trump was quick to
agree to our request this time he sought
to curate history listen to this as we
sat for the interview the president's
former president's press secretary
presented us with a with copies of a
bound volume one thousand
accomplishments of President Donald J
Trump highlights of the first term on
the back cover is the American flag the
presidential seal and Trump's thick
Jagged signature the book totals 92
pages and is organized with chapters
dedicated to the economy tax cuts
deregulation trade and so on
Trump walked into the room flanked by
plain clothes Secret Service a much
smaller detail than he once had he wore
his dark suit and tie his bronze makeup
whatever okay here is the relevant
section uh that I want to
um show you which goes to Trump's latest
uh his biggest regret this is absolutely
fascinating and very very scary over the
years Trump rarely has expressed
misgivings but he regrets his response
to protests last summer in Minneapolis
Portland Seattle and other cities now
you might hear that and say oh maybe he
regrets threatening to send in military
maybe he regrets the Despicable things
he said about protesters or defending
the police uh brutality no no no no no
I think if I had to do it again
I would have brought in the military
immediately he said what if he had
another opportunity he would have more
quickly scaled up the violence and the
repression of the protesters by the
military remember when he was thinking
about this that I and others said okay
so hold on a second
you have protests triggered by excessive
use of force by law enforcement against
George Floyd that that was the Catalyst
for these protests Trump's natural
instinct is to send in military to shut
down the protests which were
overwhelmingly peaceful that is truly
the tendency the knee-jerk reaction of
an authoritarian it's a horrible thing
now ultimately it didn't end up going
down that way and that's a very good
thing and get having a chance to do it
over again Trump says I wish I had sent
in the military more quickly
Trump had they go on to say Trump had no
such second thoughts about his handling
of the pandemic he said he had been very
tough in protecting the country by
restricting travel first from China then
Europe he said he did so against the
wishes of his top medical advisors in
fact most of them agreed with the
restrictions before he made the decision
that's true according to participants in
the discussions and their
contemporaneous notes but he correctly
said he pushed scientists at the FDA at
a level that they have never been pushed
before to get vaccines approved in
record time Trump may have been pushing
people but there is no reason to believe
based on everything we know that Trump
had anything to do with these vaccines
being approved any quicker than they
would have been without him uh this is
just a delusion one last bit of flavor
quote I think we did a great job on
covid and it hasn't been recognized
Trump said noting other countries saw
spikes in coveted infections in the
months after he left office the
cupboards were bare we didn't have gowns
we didn't have masks we didn't have
ventilators we didn't have anything we
brought in plane loads we did a great
job
when we asked Trump why he encouraged
people to believe things that weren't
true or to distrust science and the
media he delighted in talking about the
scientific smarts in his family's genes
can you imagine first of all I'm a big
person do you know this my Uncle Dr John
Trump I think he was at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
longer than any other Professor totally
brilliant man he had numerous degrees so
that's in the genes I always go with
that stuff but it's a little bit in the
genes and Dr John Trump he was a great
guy now I'm a big believer in science if
I wasn't you wouldn't have a vaccine it
depends are you talking about
disinformation or are you talking about
lies there's a more beautiful word
called disinformation so I Trump seems
to be saying he didn't lie but he did
spread disinformation which I don't know
that it actually makes it any better
horrifying and delusional and what's
very interesting is as they point out
Trump never apologizes for anything
Trump doesn't have regrets never here
you finally get him to I guess reflect
and say there is something I wish I
would have done differently I wish I
would have sent in troops to repress
protests about police brutality more
quickly just absolutely horrifying and
dystopian in absolutely every sense of
the word we have a voicemail number and
that number is 219 to David P this is a
really funny voicemail
this is someone who is admonishing me
this caller says I had better start
telling the truth about Trump's rally
crowds take a listen
hey David I'm calling about your Monday
show
um I think you and other journalists are
doing a disservice to
I don't even know if it's democracy by
not showing the number of people who are
showing up to these Trump hate rallies
right but now listen to the turnaround
here it's not what you expect it was it
was clear for Monday's show that when
the people were being in
ude in the hallway in the in the
greeting hallway of Trump's uh CPAC
rally there just weren't that many
people around but what was really
obvious was when you were panning the
audience of his rally and the and the
front row seats were clearly not filled
plus the venue that he was speaking at
it didn't look like a big venue it
looked like a venue like a small movie
theater in Suburbia or something like
that anyway
um I look forward to watching your show
every day but I do think that that
should be rectified you were completely
right you were completely right I did
not point out that uh you know Trump
claimed there were a million people at
his rally on January 6th there were not
Trump claimed there were 30 000 people
at the rally I covered I believe it was
on June 26th or maybe it was the July
3rd rally
um and it is absolutely true that his
crowds have just been weak but I want to
restate this the fact that people aren't
right now energized to go out and see
Trump speak in public means nothing
about the fact that this guy still owns
and controls and is the primary uh
individual in the Republican party let's
not forget that because if we just fall
for the small crowd stuff that's how
Trump ends up winning again and I would
say none of us some people in the
audience do want that for the most part
most of my audience recognizes that for
the House of Horrors that it would be we
have a great bonus show for you today
it's a great one I'm out of time but
just sign up at joinpakman.com com and
it'll be a surprise but it's a fantastic
bonus show we have planned for you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors ground news is
combating divisiveness in media ground
is a news comparison platform that helps
you see multiple perspectives for any
news story so you can be more of a
well-rounded news reader download the
free app at ground.news slash Pacman